bonjour bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
vidéo aujourd'hui les migrations
première partie nous allons distinguer
les migrations des différents types de
déplacements à la base cet exposé le
dictionnaire de géographie des idées
sion à pied commençons tout d'abord si
vous le voulez bien par une définition
et la définition du phénomène de
migration
la migration est un phénomène durable
souvent massif qui s'effectue sur des
distances importantes et abouti c'est un
transfert de résidence et parfois à
l'adoption d'un nouveau mode de vie
voyons les conséquences qu'entraînent
une telle définition par rapport à
d'autres types de déplacements
la migration est donc un phénomène de
longue durée
quand les déplacements porte des coups
des durées plus courtes
nous allons parler de mouvement si le
mouvement s'effectue tous les jours nous
aurons donc des mouvements quotidiens
que nous appellerons des mouvements
pendulaires il s'agit typiquement du
déplacement d'un individu de son
domicile à son lieu de travail ou
éventuellement à son lieu
d'apprentissage l'école et bien sûr le
soir le retour de ce lieu de travail de
cette école vers le domicile à l'échelle
hebdomadaire nous parlerons de
mouvements hebdomadaire chaque semaine
par exemple des militaires reviennent de
leur caserne à leur domicile et
repartent le lundi matin ou le dimanche
soir de leur domicile vers leur lieu
d'affectation
il en va de même pour les étudiants
kotteurs ou dans le cas qui nous occupe
plus particulièrement ici à verrières
des élèves internes dans le secondaire
on pouvait avoir aussi des déplacements
qui s'inscrivent sur plusieurs mois
ce sont des mouvements saisonniers parle
de 50 il y avait par exemple des
travailleurs qui vont effectuer certains
travaux dans certains secteurs comme par
exemple secteur agricole où les secteurs
touristiques
on a vraiment des travailleurs
saisonniers qui vont par exemple
réaliser les vendanges en france ou qui
vont travailler à
sur les côtes méditerranéennes où par
exemple en haute montagne pour la saison
de sports d'hiver
de la même façon la nomadisation c'est à
dire l'adoption d'un genre de vie
itinérant n'est pas considéré comme une
migration les nomades qui s'opposent aux
sédentaires sont des personnes sans
résidence fixe qui pratiquent le
nomadisme
il se déplace dans l'espace le plus
souvent au rythme des saisons ce sont
par exemple des pasteurs qui cherchent
des pâturages pour leurs troupeaux mais
aussi les forains sur les différentes
foires qui sont également des
populations nomades
le nomadisme véritable a aujourd'hui
pratiquement disparu et on parle plutôt
de semi nomade pour qualifier les
populations qui possède un lieu
d'ancrage dans l'espace à partir duquel
il organise des déplacements à ce
moment-là saisonniers enfin la migration
n'est pas non plus réductible aux
déplacements touristiques qui ne sont en
fait que des voyages même s'ils vont
parfois durer sur une période plus ou
moins longue
et s'ils vont créer de nombreux effets
dans les régions d'accueil
la mobilité est également un concept
différent elle exprime un changement de
position géographique sociale ou
professionnelle
la mobilité géographique est un
déplacement dans l'espace temporaire de
courte durée qui s'effectuent parfois
pour des motifs professionnels et qu'ils
expriment par mouvement la mobilité
sociale ou capillarité social
caractérise une évolution de statut
social qui se traduit par une ascension
ou une régression sur l'espace social
l'exemple caricatural et le pauvre qui
devient riche
cette mobilité sociale peut-être
intragénérationnelle c'est à dire au
sein d'une génération par exemple un
même individu va évoluer socialement ou
inter générationnelle si on a d'une
génération à une autre des pères par
rapport à leurs fils ou des maires par
avoir leur fille une évolution sur
l'échelle sociale
enfin cette mobilité peut être
professionnel c'est à dire qu'on va
simplement changer de métier alors
horizontale si on reste dans le même
type de qualification ou vertical s'il
ya une progression est rare
en termes de compétences cette vidéo est
fini je vous propose de passer au quiz
n'oubliez pas de noter les questions que
vous pourriez posées aux contrats courts
à bientôt